>>Laura Tyson: Hello, You Tubers, I'm Laura
Tyson, Professor of Economics and Business
at the University of California Berkley.
I can think of two things in two quite different
areas. One, I think is important for the central
banks and a number of countries of the world
to get together to try to make sure that the
world doesn't enter a global recession in
2008. I think there are things they can do.
I think the kind of international agreement
of coordination of macroeconomic policies
and exchange rates efforts could be very helpful.
At the same time I think, on a personal level,
what each individual should do is think about
ways that they can make a meaningful reduction
in their use of carbon based energy. I think
there are a lot of low hanging fruit in our
lives in terms of efficiency advancements
and I think if we do that in our homes and
our offices in our travels and we get others
to do the same thing, we'll be making progress
on the greatest challenge that confronts humanity:
that is the global climate change challenge.